[Music]
thank you
previously on segment tricks us into
thinking there will be some more Titania
action but we only get a brief shot of
her on a freaking television at the end
of the episode he's either a sorcerer
who lives in New York or a librarian who
lives in Nepal why is Nikki confused you
can see on the phone that presently he's
the sorcerer who lives in New York it's
literally the only job title listed as
present if she's going to consider the
possibility he's also still a librarian
then why no mention of the Target sales
associate listing also I feel like we
can't State enough that's arriving nine
years in retail might as well be a
prison sentence and Wong will always get
a sent off for getting out alive
the whole thing show will try to paint
this less than magic man as a simple
charlatan but never addressed the fact
that he clearly has spent more time
working on his abs than he has on his
act now I have to explain to the kids
that the issue here is not focusing on
your priorities and what is your name
young lady Madison with two ends one why
but it's not where you think you don't
think I know where your why is and I
don't know why that whole thing sounded
way more sexual than it was Donnie blade
getting a Donny Blaze win you'd have
preferred a Johnny Blaze in case she
confused it with Kathmandu Kansas we
wouldn't dare play the music Wong's
listening to but the sin is the soprano
series finale this is the one where they
kill Adriana it was so sad
you just ruined it sorry Wong that
episode of The Sopranos aired almost two
decades ago the spoiler statute of
limitations has long run out
[Music]
show doesn't actually know how I look at
least I hope not wait a second what is
that blinking light in the corner over
there I guess you saw it Wong is back
God everybody loves Wong it's like
giving the Show Twitter armor for a week
I didn't immediately jump to the
conclusion that the writers were using
Wong as a gimmick but pointing it out
this way feels pretty gimmicky the show
just managed a fourth wall break itself
into admitting that the intention was to
exploit Wong's popularity and this is
supposed to be fun for the viewer
good morning sweetheart I give Morris as
Jen's father but opening someone else's
door without knocking first is always
going to get you a sin what if Jen was
Hulk smashing a new friend she met at
the bar last night you don't want to
walk in on that Morris what's the shovel
for digging holes let's just leave it at
that I know Jen understands plausible
deniability but I'm still going to be
asking more questions about the purpose
of the shovel and not just leave it at
that and Jen should too going with
matcher instead of Mumble or hinder just
walked us of a legal situation with the
greatest importance is it though because
I have a sneaking suspicion that the
only reason it's presented as a legal
problem is that the show is titled
She-Hulk attorney at law thereby
requiring all problems that arise to be
dealt with via lawsuit instead of fight
Court Miss Walters we answer to a higher
power that abides by the metaphysical
laws of the time space continuum then
why have you come to GLK and H instead
of Consulting your higher power do you
want to leave your information with me
this time
cool trick but there's not a single
piece of contact information on this
card just to name it a title the
sorcerer Supreme is being more of a
sorcerer not listen name
did you just woo-woo a pearl breathe I
don't know enough about laws or files to
say in a strict sense what confidential
even means but I'm pretty sure your case
files fall in the category of things you
shouldn't bring to a bar even a law
themed bar I hate to see two stunning
women sitting all alone okay well
there's two of us so by definition not
alone Mickey would be Master of the
articulate Arts at bar room sins
got your ball Wong definitely did not
know where that ball had been anyway I
hate LA everyone here is so phony see
I'm a New Yorker through and through oh
how long did you live there 14 months
show is troping so hard on this bad date
that I'm surprised they didn't just give
this guy an [__] so we know that he's
an apple or did they
[Music]
I think I picked something up in the
earlier sentence I'm a state counselor I
am hard-pressed to believe that a magic
trick could constitute gross negligence
well I'm hard-pressed to believe that
this story is taking place on Earth 616
considering all the Miracles this world
has witnessed how is anything about
suspicion and how do you keep your job
as a judge and not be able to Fathom The
Disappearing people isn't a cause for
concern
ing right now this episode has raised
more legal questions about
non-consensual portaling than it has
given legal answers about pretty much
anything going on right now
Disney plus did not immediately announce
a Madison and wongers Series right after
this episode aired oh did you get a
ticket for texting just say you were
texting 9-1-1 they can't prosecute that
isn't what this is and that's not true
as it turns out texting and driving is
uniformly illegal everywhere in the U.S
except in Montana where the decision has
largely been left up to the cities and
Missouri where you have to be 21 to
indulge in the joys of distracted
driving which makes sense because you
definitely want that to coincide with
the legal consumption of alcohol no wait
that doesn't make sense so I guess the
sin is as always the Gateway Arch you
can't bring that drink in here well she
did do it so I guess you can do it even
though you shouldn't do it problem is
that judge Hannah sloppy ruling on this
cocktail is cast doubt on the legitimacy
of the whole trial Madison is with two
ends one why but it's not where you sing
I realize I sinned this turn of phrase
earlier in the episode but I also didn't
realize Patty Guggenheim would show back
up and steal the episode from every
everyone so well at least halfway make
up for my supposed error and judgment
here which honestly is so dramatic and I
hate drama the reason we've never seen
another episode of This Is Us somehow
makes its way into the episode and then
you seek are seeking to wield the power
of gods but Wong is known about Donnie
Blaze for a while now and is only taking
him to court because he sent Madison to
Wong's apartment where she spoiled a
Sopranos episode Wong clearly was not
concerned about Donnie Blaze's act
before then on men in the Mortal realm
has the ability to cause a ripple so
great it reverberates through every
Dimension and that Ripple through
galaxies has the ability to destroy all
life within the known and unknown
Universe the tonal dissonance between
the potential impact that Wong just laid
out and the slapstick litigation that's
playing out in this courtroom makes us
all ask why he is [__] around with
what is clearly an inept Supernatural
justice system instead of going full
Punisher on the situation or at least
Breaking All the Rules like former
sorcerer Supreme
I'm not proud of this show expects us to
believe that men would want to date Jen
when she's turned into She-Hulk but that
men would not want to date Jen when she
simply looked like Tatiana maslani and I
do not believe you show is there
anything worse than dating in your 30s I
mean getting unintentionally exposed to
Hulk changing radiation that's up to end
of your life which was going perfectly
fine beforehand seems like it would be
in the ballpark I'm in medicine so not
only is this a discount Jesse Williams
but he also plays a doctor I hope that
doesn't mean the show is turning into a
discount Gray's Anatomy or do I actually
want that to happen I kind of do but I
don't but I kind of do also
should we split surprise yeah let's get
those to go shoehorning in this she
horny subplot is only a sin because the
Incredible Hunk turns out to be just
another boy cliche
[Applause]
that is not a creature that gets an O
moment that is a creature that gets an
oh [__] me I'd rather you send me to the
truck stop in Pomona moment also of all
the infinite possibilities at their
disposal the writers reached into their
bag of tricks and pulled out the plot of
gremlins
things before they happen writers
thought that including clips of the
overdramatic This Is Us in the under
dramatic She-Hulk would bring balance to
the universe when we all know you need a
show willing to kill at least half of
its characters like Game of Thrones or
lost or Blake 7. also just so we're
clear I had zero clue there would be a
scene of Wong watching this is us before
I made that this is as common earlier
but here we are that probably should get
us a sin removal but also this is us so
no Tony please open the wrong portal I
need your help calling your lawyer when
you have a whole Rolodex of super
friends who are more experienced and
most likely better equipped to handle
the situation I'm not sure exactly what
I'm supposed to be doing here Wong being
too busy with his sorcerer supremeing to
realize that smash was right there
before I send my little friend here back
to his own Dimension I was wondering if
you would agree to the terms of our
cease and desist which is something Jen
should be able to get regardless after
this demonstration of how badly Donny's
magic shows can go but instead she's now
given Donnie a fighting chance with her
threat of bodily harm that he even has a
witness for what the [__] Jen She Hulk
Wong in the portal team up to make this
entrance as steamy as possible because
the show thinks that harnessing the
power of our Collective non-gender
specific boners will prevent this Skip
and it works hot doctor's a cliche
anyway she's suing you for misuse of a
trademark Oh yay trademark infringement
twist I cannot wait to
okay
I like your funny words Magic Man the
ancient art of levitation why are you
not entertain
Ed he sent me to a death dimension in a
talking goat helped me escape a lava pit
in exchange for six drops of my blood
baby
[Music]
notice how I use the word magician in
quotes not using it right Joe so first
he gave me roses that didn't smell like
anything and then he pushed me into a
fire land well perhaps the laws of
physics cease to exist on your stove the
demon I think his name is Jake Jake from
State Farm you do the same trick at a
show last week and my friend Kayla ended
up staying in a parking garage in Pomona
The Californians I'll be right back
never ever ever under any circumstances
say I'll be right back kind of a bummer
way to end this episode I bet there's a
fun tag yeah I'm Tech man I I I I live
in the tents